bien quiero utilizar este vídeo para
tratar de tener una mejor intuición
acerca de las curvas de futuros para
tener un mejor acercamiento pondré
varios precios en el mercado para tener
una mejor entendimiento acerca de las
curvas de los futuros y aquí en
particular pondré un precio en
particular de entrega para distintas
fechas pero bueno antes quiero advertir
que es un poco confuso declarar los
distintos precios y viene esta curva de
un futuro que tenemos aquí cuando tienes
una fecha de entrega de tiempo cero
meses o sea hoy y en este ejemplo la
mercancía o commodities será plata así
que si vas a salir a comprar plata o y
esta cuesta aproximadamente 32 dólares
déjame decirte que esto es por fuera por
fuera costaría 32 dólares por onza y
bien la fecha pactada sería dentro de un
mes y del precio del que estoy hablando
no es el de la plata dentro de un mes
sino el precio de hoy en el mercado si
estuvieras acordando de vender o comprar
plata en un mes el precio futuro para la
entrega dentro de un mes fuera de todo
esto ese es el correcto para hoy o sea
en este momento bueno quiero hacer más
clara
no está mostrando te como el precio de
contado de la plata se moverá dentro de
los próximos ocho meses sino que me está
diciendo que hoy si quiero tratar por
fuera ahora mismo no tendría que
tramitar o negociar a 32 dólares por
onza si hoy estás de acuerdo en negociar
plata para dentro de un mes tendrías que
negociado podrás comprar o bien vender
esto como alrededor de los 33 dólares
por onza y bueno también si estuvieras
de acuerdo para venderlo o comprarlo
dentro de unos meses tendrás que hacerlo
a 35 dólares y para ello no ser más
redundante si estás de acuerdo en
venderla dentro de ocho meses la plata o
bien comprarla con suerte alcanzaría a
negociarla a 36 dólares quizás son
repentinos movimientos en el tiempo si
por ejemplo digamos que mañana el precio
de la plata a través de cifras ordenadas
o que la gente realice una nueva
aplicación en su uso de la plata y que
tenga mayor demanda y que no se pueda
cambiar el mundo en ese momento cuando
tengas que observar a esta curva
completa se podría deslizar hacia arriba
si se desliza hacia arriba completa como
algo así y ahí no importa cuando decidas
negociar la plata de todos modos los
valores serán más caros y bueno eso sólo
fue una probadita de lo que sucede en
tiempo real y aquí de este lado voy a
dibujar como los precios se van moviendo
todo el tiempo y en diferentes
duraciones y esta bolita morada de aquí
es para decir el precio de contado justo
hoy que nos va a ir mostrando cómo va
cambiando en todo momento es una especie
de acercamiento del cambio que
tradicionalmente hacen las acciones y
nos dirá cómo luce esto pero aquí
podríamos decir que comienzan en 32
dólares y que se fueron a la alza y que
poco a poco fueron subiendo que es como
una especie de alzas y bajas durante
todo el tiempo y este es un movimiento
todo el tiempo son instantáneos hasta
las fechas de entrega y en algunos
puntos del futuro y este contrato de lo
voy a poner como de color verde te das
cuenta todos se van como moviendo
alrededor de ciertos precios así que si
aquí empezamos con el primer día del
contrato verde acordaste a negociar la
plata dentro de cuatro meses tu contrato
a verde lo estaría negociando cerca de
los 34 dólares aquí justo aquí es lo que
tramita este o negocios te justo ahora
que sería moviendo hacia adelante más
durante el tiempo del contrato y se
acerca cada vez más a la fecha de
entrega y si nos movemos un mes hacia el
futuro ahora el contrato simplemente
estaría a tres meses fuera y si te
mueves dos meses en el futuro ahora el
contrato es solamente dos meses fuera y
todo esto hasta aquí y si te mueves
cuatro meses fuera del contrato si te
das cuenta otra vez en el precio de
contado pero acordarte de negociar en
ese momento y en ese momento el precio
debería de estar igual al precio de
contado o sea que aquí habría una
especie de convergencia con el precio de
contado y esta es la misma curva para
dentro de ocho meses fuera del contrato